so tell me man last fight um sure yeah I
think I think you died for me I think
you'd want to fight Thanks
thank the RAF's man makes it rough for
stopping it those gonna kill the man
[Music]
hello this is Mike Tyson we have another
episode of hot boxing and my co-host
here is Evan hey everybody how's it
going another great day brother
beautiful day outside man I'm still
happy well we got a great guest man who
is this guy
and he does the budget the current Oh
flyweight champion of the UFC Henry
cejudo great to have him and he's going
for the welterweight title too huh thank
you guys thank you guys for having me
it's uh it's an honor to be here with
with one of the legends right here Mike
Tyson man thank you for having me Mike
yeah appreciate we from NZ originally
from actually from here originally from
LA yeah born in born in south central
back in back in 87 I think that was
around when you want don't matter he's
got it yeah but uh you know cool just uh
so I grew up out here grew up in I'm
sorry grew up in Arizona so lived in
lived in LA lived there for five years
in south-central born MLK Hospital and
then eventually uh you know eventually
just reciting in Arizona and that's kind
of where I live now how do you get
involved I mean fighting I think as a as
a kid and I think sometimes it's you
could say it's the nature and the
nurture of it right a kid from the
ghetto a kid that kind of grew up
fighting it's the it's the the struggle
of it I guess it's it's through nature
and nurture but I got into because I've
always been this you know not all great
Steve fighter than guy
the toughest to get into boxes you know
all gana fighting to go to other
directions yeah yeah and well that's
actually kind of how I started rustling
first 11 years old and then and then you
know eventually I got into got into
boxing so I have a lot of respect I did
amateur boxing for raw for some time so
it's been spent a journey and a half man
but you know just excited and happy to
be here man
awesome so tell me man the last fight um
dalish or he was here some complained
about the stoppage other situation
happen yeah I think I think you I think
you know for me I think you'd want to
probably thank the thank the raft man
think the ref for stopping it because I
was gonna kill the man so a lot of
people say you know but it's it's it's
the fibers manage it and deep down
inside I mean I think I think Mike you
can you can attest to this is you know
we're all kind of sore losers you know
until we can't accept it yeah and so and
I think some people just demonstrated
more and you know TJ would be pissed off
yeah he's really I mean like I said I
would have wished the rough wood a
louder maybe another another another ten
seconds just to just to kind of finish
the job that tap out so but taking out a
legend like him man it's it's it feels
good man it's it's it's it's gonna be
it's gonna be in my position right now
man especially with them trying to get
rid of the fly wood division mmm getting
rid of my division so and why would they
do that how would they be entitled to do
it not enough people in the division
yeah well no it's not that it's just I
think the USC has always found our
division a little you know a little
boring I guess you could say remember
Demetrius Johnson dominated this this
division for the last freakin 12 you
know for the relax I think the last six
seven years until i betta you know
Dimitri Johnson was such a dominant
fighter but he really wasn't much of a
show man like the UFC wanted so he was
beating everybody up he was dominating
buddy so the division sucks
but the reality is is I felt like he had
to be a little more showman and there's
a little and there's a little credit
that she had to give Connor man whether
you like him or not he's putting us on
the map you know there's a lot of
fighters out there like that they're
great fighters but they have no
showmanship they have no character no
one wants to see them you know one's
interesting yeah they're not colorful
enough yeah right I think and I think
that's part of it Mike I think that's
that's just that's what it is but now
that I'm hearing like I wanna I want to
resurrect a you know coming out with the
snake when I beat it to the ground I
mean things like that I mean that's
that's being a showman like it has
nothing to do with me me being a punk or
whatever right yeah and Plus and
absolutely you meet it though too
at the same time for sure you're
describing your mind to your opponents
like I'm gonna grab that snake I'm gonna
whip it on its head and I would kill it
right yeah the thing of when I was
finally the same they had him in an
unpredictable cycle tough guy and stuff
day but the people liked and stuff was
that a conscious choice for you Mike
yeah I knew that's that's just a role I
had to go you were going out as the
monster yeah yeah so talk a little bit
about that man as a fighter and sort of
developing your character on the stage
because that's what it is right I mean
that's kind of that's what Connor does
doesn't it I mean is he like that
talking [ __ ] like if we were hanging out
here would he be just talking [ __ ] he
might be ya know he's a good guy man I
think I think it's a to better persona
but I think now he's at the point where
I think he's actually starting to
believe it and that's a scary thing
because now as I think I'm get the lose
you know fight it we get to lose you
know yeah yeah and I've always tried to
maintain myself like knowing that like
hey man I'm good I'm great I'm a world
champ but I'm not I'm not something I'm
not sometimes we believe we're gods no
in that human yeah
that's that's powerful yeah right is a
trip
I gotta want to say but it's a that's
powerful Mike said you know absolutely
like you were we're we're we're David
yeah
always no matter who you're fighting you
feel as though you're the underdog and
you have to be ready to kill I think
that's a really interesting thing about
the Warriors path you know because you
reach this certain level of success
you've defeated so many opponents and
your ego really begins can begin to take
over if you don't keep it in check yeah
how do you keep that in check every it's
uh it's a healthy it's a healthy nervous
like you have to be you have to be
healthy nervous you know you got to be
confident you have to have that healthy
nervous if you don't have that healthy
nervous do you're really he really over
your head man and if you don't check
that what happens is as fighters start
to they they start to lose and it
becomes a domino effect you know and
it's it's and then later you just start
hitting the sport man it it happens yes
it happens hmm you start hating the
sport yeah yeah that makes sense
that happened to me in football too yeah
I started hating it that healthy nervous
feeling that's this feeling of I've
always got to be training my ass off
preparing the best I can because I could
lose I I'd say that and probably a a bit
of a respect for your opponent like you
have to be like hey man this dude could
possibly beat me and you got to see all
these strengths and all these weaknesses
you got to analyze everything that you
know about yourself and then everything
that you know about him and then you'll
reflect on the strengths and weaknesses
like it's very it's very profound as
very profound for you to think like that
and if you ain't thinking like that man
it's it starts internal man like this is
an I don't want to say it's all in your
head because
that's very cliche its internal
something much deeper than then then
then then then passion it is also you
can't explain him because like on the
flip side didn't invest the guys when
they Eagles taking like this good I'm
gonna train for him the [ __ ] bum hmm
am i worth day I can beat him I'm bigger
than her yes people thank all men the
eagle is just takes you to dark places
it's it's scary man that's why you need
the toad yeah every once in a while
check in with the toes you know about
the toad Henry something like that so
it's actually a cold exactly a told in
the Sonoran Desert the Sonoran Desert
Mexico Mexico and it hibernates like ten
months out of the year and when you
capture it it had venom in this that's
poor so just be great open up your
busses you put in a shootout and went on
a glass cartons it you take it off the
glass you put it in a pipe you smoke it
and then you um you become reborn again
have you heard of DMT DMT ayahuasca yeah
ayahuasca yeah so you know what Mike's
talking about is you experience like an
ego death you die you see all of your
trauma and pain and everything that's
happened to you in your life and it
really comes together in a way that
gives you context about you know who you
are and what your purpose is and people
are cured of addiction and depression
and anxiety all of this stuff from doing
this toad and what it does is I think is
it shows you that we are all connected
you know that we are all part of Henry's
like I've smoked a little too much
yes good hold it here
I died and came back to life really I
think it's an incredible medicine for
fighters for any warrior you know
because it it brings you back to that
place you know of humility and love and
so that it's a good balance for you in
the midst of having to prepare yourself
for battle over and over again mm-hmm
anyway it's just interesting man Henry
that's crazy man that's crazy all these
all these different natural remedies yes
and everything's out there about us as
humans we have to discover that yeah you
know know people people inform us be
it's not have to not to read the
messages you know and that's listen
listen right hmm Mike's like hanging out
with a sage you know like the wives
elders of the tribe it's crazy but you
know I tried it in the form of a younger
we didn't want to listen
yeah yeah yeah listen before I involve
myself with the toad this I don't think
the way he could tell me she think I've
seen the world a couple of times I've
been around some interesting people and
I ain't thinking the way I can tell me
[ __ ] you know as I told and I'm like
[ __ ] I realize I didn't know anything I
realized I was afraid all those years I
was actually afraid you know my little
my ego just start going on oh god I'm
dying [ __ ]
I was crying to the guy I'm dying on I'm
dying and I was so friend and know how
to live without my ego you know not live
without that somebody confront you get
what [ __ ] assembly goes once man
confront you like [ __ ] what do I do you
know and I was a scary situation for me
you know I used to know what to do I
thought I was dying I didn't know what
to do like [ __ ] I'm missing my kids my
wife everything's leaving me [ __ ] and I
was happy with it that's powerful
medicine dude it's powerful you guys got
me thank you man I want some of this
tone yeah
yeah it's miraculous fifty members like
for every 15 minutes a long time in your
head nodding your head 15 minutes is a
long time god oh oh so it's only 50
minutes that that only like two hours of
15 minute blast off oh man you don't
want one in 15 minutes well you know
ayahuasca which is a little bit less
intense that's like 12 hours yeah I can
handle that stuff it's a 12 hour rod
that one thing that one head equipped
boom you just go wow your life flashes
right in front of you men stop breathing
and he's like [ __ ] hearing music and
sound take me places yeah it's like it's
like have you ever had an experience
with death that's what it is yeah no no
besides besides you know doing something
like the besides dueler natural remedy
have you ever like got caught like
almost drowning people shot at me but I
ran and got away well that's what this
is Henry tell us about have you had one
I've had and that's that's kind of how
when Tyson talks about that you know
you're like your life flashes before
your eyes it's its death yeah it's what
kind of flashes before your eyes but
it's like uh it's this it's this memory
assist video that goes through you but
you're it's it's in real motion it's
like you're it's like you're watching
yourself right now just seeing your
whole life just go I'm gonna run through
your eyes you know and your mind and
you're just like so when you're talking
about that experience I'm just like I
thought I thought of like it's real man
like it's real like dude I this is this
is crazy like I'm dead or um or I'm
better or I'm coming alive listen the
only people if nothing physical or
psychological you don't feel nothing
it's not as you saw what you see the
visual stuff Henry tell us about your
near-death experience um you know it was
uh poof it was it was it was a few years
ago and they know I'm sorry it was about
a couple years ago man I got caught up
in the California the Santa Rosa fires
and I had to escape from
from a hotel you know ii had to jump out
the window that i was like the last one
i kid how all right what that I would do
well then fire everything you ready for
blaze that he can't breathe can't see so
I'm talking about like the whole hotel
was just lit lit up lit up on fire never
even jumped out like 3/4 of it was like
done everything with all the houses in
front of me they're all burnt to sticks
cars on fires of buildings next to me on
fire not jumping out that window
but that's kind of what I do yeah that's
what happens like your your life flashes
before your eyes
like it's like [ __ ] becomes real well in
those experiences they say you're
getting a hit of your own natural DMT
because DMT is produced in your third
eye and your pineal gland and you get a
hit of it when you're born when you come
into your mother's womb there's your
first hit of DMT and then your next hit
of DMT you get to in your life as when
you die so having a near-death
experience they say could trigger a
blast of DMT naturally so that's why
people say oh I felt I saw my life flash
before my eyes because you did that was
your soul going oh [ __ ] it's time to go
and lifting my thumb if we're in I could
um I did around three times I want to do
it again what I'm so scared
do it again you know life flashing
before your eyes before your eyes if
that's the feeling like I don't know I
don't know if that's
you're watching it yeah some people do
it once some people do it one time some
people never do it some people are like
crazy about it do it all the time
so you guys you guys tempted me hey man
we're just offering it that this is this
is an option in the world you know that
when you're ready it's I think I believe
that you're called to these medicines
you know you start seeing them you start
hearing about them you start educating
yourself and then the time is right for
you to do it you know but that's on your
journey it's not about somebody going
here dude it's time now that's not what
it is
ya know right right but dude let's get
back to the real world let's get back to
reality
you brought your beautiful championship
belt then what did it feel like to win
that to earn that generally I stand in
fighter a fighter yeah it's uh it's a
satisfaction it's a satisfaction feeling
that that lets you know let you know
okay everything that I've been doing is
right
finally the stuff that I'm thinking up
here is manifesting physically and so
it's more of a feeling to me like being
a world champion is more about those
feelings to me it's not it's not so much
the number but it's the emotion that
comes with one in that belt because in
every camp you get hurt and every camp a
lot of things happen and you don't you
know you start that that starts to enter
you and you had to make sure to check it
so when you win and you win a big fight
like that against a very high opponent
man it's like all right man I may be an
eye you become kind of an a legend like
an instant legend though because you
beat Demetrius Johnson who's probably
one of the greatest of all time and then
you go out and beat the greatest
bandwidth of all times like dude I'm on
top of that you know being the best in
the world in another sport it's it
leaves my print in the sport and someone
you know and in that special
me too because like you know what I did
this yeah I always someone I was
fighting I always wanted to be a part of
that fraternity I want them to know my
name was you know what I'm dead in this
thing you know my name is you know
implanted in this fraternity here
there's you know thousands of guys are
gonna come after I die and they say you
know you didn't let see a picture and
[ __ ]
yeah it's powerful man let me leave your
mark on your spoon so that's that's more
the celebrations to me I guess for the
most part it just it means the world to
me man really does that's cool man
you've been working since you were 11
I mean brother the fifties you have I'm
one of seven kids so one of seven a half
I'm sorry three other brothers and then
three sisters so I can I come from a big
big family how was that the the the
upper engines is fight of the family
came out yeah yeah very you know very
you know it's a minority family Mexicans
you know we're all close but you know
you do fight a lot as a family man you
know so the upbringing was was was very
we fought a lot at the same time it's we
helped each other a lot you know we
showed each other love so I come from
that kind of type of family you still
close to two brothers and sisters now
yeah all of them my brothers and sisters
are all right yeah they all come to my
fight someone that doesn't come to my
fight is my mom really yeah she don't
she doesn't like it she don't like that
stuff yeah it's tough to watch your baby
get right it's it's hard what about you
Mike anybody uh the people that she grew
up with anybody ever
anybody ever not come to your fights are
not like you fighting the Jomon like you
fighting so my mother passed away before
I started fighting no I wasn't one of
those guys
that people say oh god he's gonna get
hurt you know Matt we just wanna knows
I'm imposing figures at that particular
time that you know I was the guy doing
the damage you know you feel sorry for
the other guy you know me I don't know
you didn't have that kind of affection
for people they felt sorry anything else
they get hurt they never totally get
hurt and stuff like that so I got hurt
yeah what was the first time you got
hurt like did you get hurt in a fight
yeah I'm gonna fight in 1990 in Japan
with Buster Douglas and stuff people
were really worried and concerned it
still had a really big high intrusion
hmm and I've never looked before but
I've lost the amateur before and I
understood loss I never saw a loss that
averages 15 was just as bigger the
losses being champ of the world of me at
the time the fastest the thought of
losing and my ego and my fat my
psychological way of looking at fighting
and the act of losing it really gave me
a really bad psychological opinion about
myself
dad I didn't do son right which is
normally the case it'll loss yeah but
you learn so much from your life
absolutely absolutely
very painful you have to think and if I
look at yourself and your character in
fact this is what you really want to do
that you really want take a possibility
of going through that again
yeah that's deep and I think that's what
I think that's what's made him the best
in the world is the way he the way you
were the way you carry a loss these are
a lot of a lot of people have to a lot
of people have to almost really how can
I say work on work on the mind we do to
understand what it's like to accept
defeat but not become bitter because of
it or to bitter they can turn around and
bite you in the butt - yeah give
yourself a dark shadow it's all about
you to know that this is this is a sport
and with two guys than the best man
and when there's no fight afterwards
it's not personal
no I always have that objective
nothing's personal hmm
hen review had a tough loss that you
know you learned a lot from yeah I'd say
the losing to Demetrius the first time
for the when I fought him the first time
they beat me like he'd knocked me out in
two minutes man 2 minutes and 36 seconds
to the body I don't know you've ever
been stopped to the body man listen my
first time I'm a boxer muddy
I hit me in the body and I just went
down right away I stopped breathing and
breathe yeah and you know I equated to
not breathing to dying I couldn't
breathe eyes notifier I couldn't even
cry but I wanted to cry back it's no air
no nothing I didn't do anything
that's what you felt that's what I felt
mad but at the same time it physically
it hurts yeah
physically it hurts but it's but anyways
but it's also very humiliating because
you're conscious a knockout is different
if you get knocked out you pushed me out
I'm out I wake up and I'm just like hey
what happened is it Christmas it's it
seemed humiliating because you get hit
to the body do you can your conscience
and your just curling up like a little
girl
you know yeah because your systems just
shutting down body punches right anybody
all right
anybody could I don't care who you are
tough see anybody could make a boom
getting the chicken knocked on blackout
and it's over you've got hit in the
black belt out his stomach right you
make
thing hey I want to do this [ __ ] no more
hmm I mean I can't move no more that's
what happened yeah the body shuts down
so the next time you fought him how did
you defend from his body punches
well I that but that's what I'm saying I
had a uh I had a really strengthen my
core I had a that was one of it one of
the areas and and that but I think more
important than that is making sure that
my Waco was done even better correctly
and that's kind of what fatigued me it
was it was a cut it was a few things man
and then the problem is when you get hit
to the body gets stopped you start to be
very cautious with your body man you
change it you can change it louder
you could change as a fighter because
you're so fearful yeah although the
smaller guy neighbor always told me so
very hard to get to my body that I
normally do headshots and I knew where
they had to go punch of that so you took
a lot of head shoulder shots I don't
think we shot it off yeah yeah you learn
from it you move on and as a competitor
I think I had him on my hit list like
really it became personal almost a
defeat like that becomes extremely
person it became extremely personal to
me so I knew that I knew that I had to
sacrifice a lot to be to beat a man out
of his caliber like a man fellow if I
thought I was doing [ __ ] right then who
it just got worse
it showed you what you had to do to have
next level who's your favorite fighter
growing up is there somebody you watched
somebody who idolized it actually it
started it started more with boxing
actually and even still to this day like
I almost prefer watching a good high
like world championship boxing fight
then gonna be hard to see one yeah but
if you could find somebody like if you
get two good like you know triple G
canal was a good fight triple G canal
was a good fight
I would prefer watching a boxing fight
like that then probably any UFC fight
and in the world I really do because
boxing the the world is so it's so
ancient it's it's it's reached its peak
I mean it's it's at its best boxing yeah
were where MMA is still evolving
mmm-ma got some awesome personalities in
there yeah John Jones got cornered and
got a little guy here that people don't
got enough mom what's the new guy Israel
he got an awesome personality got hungry
yeah all I'm talking about all those
guys he didn't they category - yeah no
telling new guys yeah it's exciting it's
definitely exciting it's just - almost
if you fight it much I was a fighter and
you should know you should know
professionally if you're if you're
mostly attached to somebody like a
fighter somebody if he knows you feel
like [ __ ] your [ __ ] you wanna [ __ ]
knock those you know you experiment you
want to fight the other guys - [ __ ]
clan us yeah you're really mad yeah you
guys you know you're your passions are
too high and fighting they always gotta
be cooked control yourself it's amazing
there's not more mayhem at these fights
more fights don't break out on the sides
you know well it happened he saw have a
good even Khan either got older he
didn't stuff that happens with human
beings you know yeah so what's your next
thing man what are you doing right now
yeah open for some acting gigs anything
I see that yeah take over take over take
over Latin America right soap opera man
I think I was in its it could be
possible you know could be mr. mr.
Casanova every night Saturday 7:00 p.m.
Telemundo
put it out there bring that money in no
I actually I would I would like to uh
get into after I'm done defining I want
to get into real estate I really uh I
you know I love the sport of MMA I love
wrestling but I could never I could
never do it max I understand the
commitment that it has so I wanna I want
freedom in my life myself I wanna get
into real estate and and I want to
continue to keep like doing motivational
speaking or whatnot like all across the
country it's great man how many more
fights you think you got in you we have
a lot of faith in you but you only want
certain amount twenty in you but you
only won three yeah yeah Dan I say
that's that's a that's a good way to put
it right that's a good way to put it
because the body could take a lot or it
can't take that much but you're thinking
you're just thinking different thinking
more and you're but you're giving less
so I think that I think that talks yet
to be determined man I don't see myself
going past thirty four though told you I
just turned 32 34 35 oh you're 87 80 72
okay I'll be 32 in October
energy dude we were like let's drop into
that [ __ ] that's cool mask that's cool
when you do meet somebody that's that's
your year - I because there's there's
camaraderie there's a there's a
connection yeah yeah I just had my 366
min we had bad drug errors and all that
stuff these guys like gangbangers then
all that stuff man ladies wipe 260
babies out Henry tell me if I'm wrong
but I feel like being born in 87 coming
up in the early 90s we have this really
interesting experience of like seeing
the Internet come up and seeing social
media be created and we were really at
the time to like grow with all this [ __ ]
oh yeah the foliage in ping get to ring
the phone like that yes ice is going
back another two generations ice
interesting I have a nephew who's 23 or
24 and I still feel like even that's the
separation yeah yeah for sure like that
that generation is yeah like well you
really have a turning point too and when
you turn get into your 30s I mean
something really happens like 27 to 30
[ __ ] starts to really change I think in
just your mentality about what life is
you know you get more focused you know
you get more just dialed in ma'am you
know you've got less time for [ __ ]
you've seen some stuff you've learned a
lot you know your 20s are a tough time
and then when you getting your fifties
like me still one guy I'm I'm going to
be able to [ __ ] my wife hey Mike you got
some good herbs for that yeah tell me
about that you better be taking a lot of
that oh there's some great herbs man
ginseng
this guy no stem of t [ __ ] it's
awesome it's like horny goat weed have
you heard it up yeah yeah getting in
your fifties man you seen so much I'm um
I can't remember my rap Fritz blew up
you know when I first started when the
only thing we let's do with R&B before
it and wrap his blue up sugar they're
like rappers divan you know this guy
used to hang out with Tupac ya know this
is just so wild to see this guy was um
this guy's now almost like a saint now
you know so they're so legendary dude
yeah how was it how was it how was it
hanging out with with with - did you
call - or to partner it's Parker duper
Hassan the guy is amazing he got shot I
mean I'm time in prison so he got shot
I'm in prison I wanna hear but from
either your mic menu your book is here
came and visited me so somebody um I'm
come from the gym and I get someone else
is coming from the childhood and
something yo Mike you you're mad at you
they came visit after he got they hit
him up or something crazy to that effect
and so I got I ran I went to my cuz this
one he was killed
no I wouldn't shock New York I got three
way there are three ways to way what I
think he and how they came around away
with I talked to him and um he was
telling me was it was just crazy in
there I don't know what happened it was
just really bad it shot up really bad
and um I asked my feel who wasn't he
said he had mentioned some names who it
was you know he knew who we absolutely
do we know who it was in the public does
the public know who that was why I don't
know they probably do but he's just
anybody have know anybody um have their
conspiracy conspiracy yeah we've done it
you know - what's it have done it [ __ ]
was so crazy then dude we were shooting
each other [ __ ] killing each other
yeah
yeah / / entertainment really think
about it like over over what over poetry
hey dude we the killer
we used to kill each other over a whole
lot less I mean somebody [ __ ] a pair
of Jordans poking my car life wasn't
worth anything in the 80s man life is
worth nothing man but think about it
I'll get the devic wishes it was it was
real man people just you walking over
people in the streets in a big city you
walking over people you got people walk
staggering across this right across from
these yeah yeah you think I'm just
thinking how strong as a weed is I see
what I see my trial out at that job for
about the last 30 somebody please help
Mike Tyson man I'll be honest with you
Mike I'm I've always I you know as a man
you always / you always portrayed your
very uh you know as somebody that grew
up watching you watching your ranks or
whatnot and known about you you come out
like this freak this beast man like they
don't you just you don't cross that
beast what I'm saying is that's the
persona that a lot of a lot of us have
have about you - Tyson's like I was like
I was kind of I'm still afraid of them
man I'm yeah I'm afraid that I got two
minutes I love where I am now look the
world we them in a little association I
am with the guys here it just starts did
you start smoking uh recently on my life
but um yeah I used up the drugs - I used
liquor and I used write a prescription
drugs and I was mixing all that stuff
and I was just suicidal I was in the
psych ward a couple of times okay Mike
let's do a little juxtaposition go for
it
old Mike poor pre toad Mike what was
your favorite drug I don't know it told
me she didn't even want to think about
any drugs I knew I knew you're gonna say
the toad was just the end all anyone
think about this stuff no more you know
you're thinking about having a better
life yeah and how much um if you just
get out of your own way how much life is
on your side yeah what are you that way
what do you think about weed man cuz
it's like you know it's so stigmatized
and yet it's just it helps in so many
ways and what does it do for you do you
think hey listen man this is what I know
what it does I know without it I'm a
miserable [ __ ] I'm an irritable
miserable not kind to be around guy you
know wouldn't I love everybody I know
sounds weird and strange is just as
relaxing me and um it evokes feelings of
just happiness with me relaxation such a
good answer some countries I don't go to
because if I'm there for more than a
certain amount of time I won't go if I
could they they ban weed I won't go I
don't care how much they pay me I won't
crazy skin I wouldn't be that people in
like my wouldn't be nice I was miserable
without it miserably it's a bit
irritable my wife won't like me no it's
just I couldn't do it it's powerful man
because so many people are walking
around this country can't go ten minutes
without a cigarette or you know as tear
or pollen multiple pills just to get
through the day and yet you know with
weed they want to think it's different
you know myself without long to put my
friends and cannabis I would be and I
would just be a ugly story about me when
it turned out pretty good you know it's
just very healing Henry you didn't think
this were going to be what the pod was
did you I would speak I was thinking
more of a kind of like a CN n type
interview [ __ ] reeling no you guys
catch me bye see you guys catch me by
different angles left hook right hand
sneak-attack
mind what do you think ng about
immortality death it won't say fifty you
start thinking about that [ __ ] yeah and
it's get scary to hear your mom kind of
talk about it like yeah she's old the
woman they start talking about that's
when we get I hate you tell I kid me
you know kids looking for you look fine
what's wrong
we're gonna have another fifty years you
sound like that yeah it happens all it's
it's it's scary obviously man it's you
know you don't know you don't know when
when your time is been so I mean if I
hope I hope when I die I hope it's a
hope as fast and quick sometimes I don't
know I just think that before took the
toad there's sometimes the told me she's
just really open and willing to it it
wasn't hard to die I think the time
wasn't difficult dying yeah it's
powerful to it's powerful you know this
idea of immortality
you know you've seen like vampire movies
or you know whatever where somebody
can't die it sounds like a curse when
you really get to it because if you can
never
die then you're constantly just being
put through watching everyone else
around you had me none
that's worse than dying right dying have
to be glorious because life is glorious
and so that life can be glorious if
death wasn't glorious hmm
you know we have never experienced death
you know I mean really in the way that
we understand it and we could tell
somebody else what it's about you know
we don't know that person experienced
when he died know me no one knows where
he goes they're just black
everything's just black and quiet look
at this thing right here dude it's just
falling look at this thing hey that
little bug that's right here no look
look at this look at this yeah yeah yeah
what is that
what the [ __ ] is that tripping balls
[Laughter]
nice weed this weed is laced with the
toad laced it up I knew it I knew it you
guys got me we done today Angie I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be doing a couple I'm
gonna I'm just here I'll help doing some
PR man for you know kind of just
promotional agent you were gonna
investment people doing investments and
doing some kind of sponsorships with you
tic tacs with them what is that
beautiful teeth I feel my teeth got
stopped out you left that market
yourself I mean your money now you got
Asir said I can be like I can do
commercials for take that yes
and yeah that you lacy with that toe you
side of blame I do face blame I do Sonic
Oh real quick real quick thank you so
much for coming on give a little shout
out let us know where can people check
you out they follow you know where to
get you anything no uh no just my
Instagram I just want to say more than
anything thank you my take you to the
fans thank you it's it's it's awesome
being the chap man and it's just thanks
to you guys like it's you guys make it
possible for us but you know it's I know
we're hard I sometimes we can't do
everything for you guys and take
pictures of whatnot but uh just you know
thank you guys it's awesome dude
off the rails episode Mike this is a
good one angry that was a good one
thank you again Henry appreciates you
brother good luck to you with everything
I'm gonna get that duck chin all right
Delta chant oh yeah bro carry that thing
dude did that until next time everybody
this was hot boxes and I'm Mike Tyson
I'm eben Britain we'll see you all next
time
see these
[Music]